[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gardez où est-ce que je vous emmène
aujourd'hui on est au Portugal on n'est
pas très loin au sud de Lisbonne pour
venir voir ce véhicule là alors je vous
avais déjà emmené mais c'était pas ici
c'était en Espagne n'était pas loin de
Sitges c'était au mois de février ici il
fait beau il fait chaud en novembre mais
on a un temps estival c'est génial on va
donc se regarder aujourd'hui ladybos ça
y est il est prêt il est commercialisé
on peut venir l'acheter on peut le
commander on va donc l'essayer on va sur
la route on va regarder comment il est
facile d'intéressant oui non quoi
comment vous êtes prêt allez on y va
[Musique]
alors première sensation c'est une
plateforme MEB alors plateforme je vais
pas vous parler technique dans
l'automobile allez voir des journées
automobiles mais la plateforme B j'ai
déjà essayé sur l'ID 4 j'ai fait je sais
pas si j'ai fait de Lady 3 donc je l'ai
déjà rencontré plusieurs fois et bon
voilà c'est bien c'est efficace ça
fonctionne bien premier truc que je vois
là on a un GPS qui nous emmène à un
resto où on va aller manger parce que
c'est important de manger en fait ce que
j'aurais aimé vu qu'on est sur Emmanuel
qui est quand même vachement
technologique avec une belle promesse
technologique on est vraiment entre d'un
côté le côté un peu old school du Combi
le côté marrant le côté un peu année 50
60 revival on part on se fait un feu de
camp et on se marre mais Volkswagen nous
dit c'est hyper technologique vous avez
de Lady like bref il y a plein de trucs
je vais vous expliquer le truc que je
regrette et que j'ai vu notamment dans
Lady 4 si je dis pas de bêtises
notamment c'est la conduite tête haute
c'est à dire le fait de voir ben tiens
là tu vas tourner à droite
tout avoir sous les yeux ma navigation
sous les yeux ma vitesse sous les yeux
samedi à quelle vitesse je dois rouler à
quelle vitesse je suis et si je l'ai pas
et je trouve ça un peu frustrant de pas
l'avoir mis dans une dans un véhicule
qui se veut hautement technologique ça
veut pas dire qu'il l'est pas ça veut
dire que ce petit truc en plus ça
m'aurait plus on aurait pu
[Musique]
le combi c'est quoi le combi à la base
c'est le T1 alors il y a eu différentes
versions le terrain je passe un peu
l'histoire mais le combi d'origine c'est
ça c'est l'histoire qui est parti il y a
70 ans dans les années 50 où on avait
cette idée de liberté avec ce qu'on lui
reconnaissa par Mimi alors là vous avez
un combi qui est intéressant parce que à
l'intérieur là tu as donc deux places
devant c'est en fait c'est une vraie
grande banquette ici et puis trois
places trois vraies places à l'arrière
donc ça c'est juste hyper canon donc on
peut venir grimper dedans on peut le
voir ce qu'on dit et juste hyper cool
regardez coucou là voilà donc là c'est
vraiment vraiment complètement vintage
le truc est complètement d'époque donc
on voit qu'entre le T1 des années 50 et
Lady buzz qui sort en 2022 franchement
il y a une évolution mais énorme que ce
soit à l'avant mais également à
l'arrière mais il y a une autre version
du terrain qui est juste hyper canon qui
est juste là où là on va avoir un
habitat qui est un petit peu différent
ou là on pourra venir se poser et là on
est en face à face donc là il y a un
côté convivialité en plus là vous avez
grands espaces ça venait se lever donc
une fois de plus dans l'idée du partage
dans l'idée de la découverte dans l'idée
de l'aventure de l'Escapade ça c'est
génial alors c'est toujours un peu la
même idée aujourd'hui la configuration
est plus du tout même dans l'IDH que ce
qu'on a ici mais voilà l'esprit reste et
c'est quand même ce qui nous intéresse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il existe en version familiale avec deux
vrais places à l'avant et 3 places à
l'arrière mais il existe également
version utilitaire version cargo c'est
plus pour les professionnels vous pouvez
venir charger du matériel tout en
gardant ce design hyper canon de Lady
buzz et si vous aimez la couleur la
couleur il y en a ici chez Volkswagen
avec cette taille d'immeuble on l'a en
vert on l'a en orange on l'a en jaune on
l'a en bleu bref vous avez que
l'embarras du choix
[Musique]
c'est un truc que j'avais déjà repéré
avec ladybug quand on l'avait découvert
au mois de février c'est qu'il braque
énormément on a un rayon de braquage qui
est dingue alors je vous fais la petite
démo je fais gaffe parce que normalement
je fais des choses qui sont pas trop
autorisés mais en termes de rayon
braquage le truc c'est juste démentiel
vous braquez d'un côté de l'autre vous
passez où vous voulez c'est tellement
facile tellement pratique ça c'est
génial et c'est super impressionnant
fortnite parce que si vous voulez
effectivement pas vous embêter vous
sentir de toutes les situations c'est
super simple
[Musique]
vous savez ce qu'on dit le diable se
cache dans les détails il y a énormément
de détails dans Lighty boss qui en font
une voiture très à part et assez
exceptionnelle regardez juste en haut
ici sur la vitre vous avez une Idy buzz
dessinée et un parapluie un parapluie
pourquoi parce que lorsqu'il pleut et
c'est le cas tout de suite voyez le
temps n'est pas toujours génial au
Portugal et bien vous êtes abrité ça
vous sert de parapluie alors sur le côté
vous avez des petites bandes noires à
l'arrière au niveau du coffre on peut se
demander à quoi ça sert à regarder vous
les prenez en fait vous avez un petit
scratch derrière vous le tournez comme
ça et vous venez caler vos bagages donc
ça c'est cool comme ça vous êtes sûr que
quel que soit le remplissage de votre
coffre et ben rien ne bougera d'un côté
comme de l'autre si vous avez une
caravane vous voulez venir tracter
regardez vous avez votre attelage vous
tirez ici vous avez la petite bitonio
qui sort hop vous le prenez vous le
posez et vous pouvez tracter
[Musique]
des petits Idy boss qui sont cachés dans
votre voiture vous voyez juste ici à
l'arrière très malin et là ils nous ont
même mis une petite prise 12 volts bon
voilà histoire de se marrer et là vous
avez plein de petits compartiments qui
sont positionnés là pourquoi parce que
je crois que c'est l'année prochaine va
arriver une version 7 places donc là
effectivement c'est déjà une 5 places
vous aurez deux places de plus donc
peut-être qu'ils ont anticipé de mettre
des rangements pour le gobelet peut-être
des prises USB c ça paraîtrait logique
parce que ils ont mis déjà un peu
partout dans l'habitacle truc qui est
assez malin pouvez venir bouger ici
directement votre siège avancez ou
reculer comme vous voulez ici la petite
tablette pour se mettre des petites
boissons pour se mettre des trucs légers
petite console si on a envie de se
marrer on la prend on l'arrange c'est
très pratique on retrouve également ici
à l'arrière un petit idybuzz qui est
planqué sur le côté au niveau du
plastique intégravé ils ont mis tous les
côtés je trouve ça assez marrant quand
même commence par de voiture connectée
ils ont mis de l'usb-c je voulais venir
vous brancher vous avez votre petite
prise qui est juste là il y en a une là
il y en a également une de l'autre côté
et vous en ai mis un petit smiley qui
est planqué juste ici au niveau du cache
vis je vous l'ai dit le diable se cache
dans les détails sans oublier de l'usb-c
ici mais également côté conducteur et si
vous voulez venir mettre une dashcam
dans votre voiture vous avez été assez
malin ils ont mis également une prise
usb-c juste en haut pour venir
l'alimenter et au centre ils ont fait un
truc qui est assez marrant s'appelle la
base box alors vous direz bon ok c'est
un élément central oui sauf que vous
avez un petit bouton vous pouvez venir
l'enlever alors l'enlever pourquoi me
direz-vous et bien parce que si vous
regardez je vais vous le montrer vous
avez à l'arrière des grands rangements
pratiques mais là ils vous ont mis une
carte du monde et vous allez voir votre
petit boss qui sont le côté qui du coup
peut venir parcourir le monde entier et
de l'autre côté vous avez également un
rangement qui situe juste là autant vous
dire qu'ici les rangements vous en avez
un peu de tous les côtés si vous voulez
venir mettre j'en sais rien une petite
boisson faites comme vous voulez mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là après vous venez vous
le reposez Takis clipse ils ont fait un
truc qui est extrêmement malin vous avez
des petits compartiments mais surtout si
vous venez prendre cette partie là
regardez vous avez une icône dessus ça
c'est un petit grade grave qui servira
lorsque vous avez du givre sur votre
pare-brise vous prenez vous grattez et
après vous le repositionnez là où il est
et également là ça c'est le petit clou
du spectacle vous avez un petit un
décapsuleur comme ça si vous voulez
venir vous ouvrir une bouteille de coca
sans alcool ou de ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez le faire c'est extrêmement
pratique et après vous venez les mettre
comme vous voulez pour avoir la taille
que vous voulez le niveau de vos
rangements c'est une simple glissière on
le prend on glisse on grip c'est terminé
côté conducteur sur la gauche vous avez
toute une partie au niveau des phares de
l'antibrouillard du dégivrage il y a pas
de bouton vous posez votre doigt c'est
tactile c'est assez sympa je trouve ça
vraiment bien et surtout il y a vraiment
un look qui est très particulier on
retrouve voyez cette espèce d'oranger
alors cette espèce d'oranger il est
assez marrant parce que dans les années
60 70 il y avait beaucoup d'orangers on
le voit dans les cuisines de nos
grands-mères dans nos parents j'en sais
foutrement rien mais ça revient c'est
pas kitch mais il y a un côté un peu
rétro moderne qui est très sympa et avec
des formes aussi des design voyez un peu
losanges qui existaient une fois de plus
à l'époque années 60 plus qu'elle est 70
mais qui ont quand même vécu les années
70 donc on le retrouve là et c'est assez
rigolo et sur le côté également aussi
ouais avec votre petit smiley comme sur
tous les modèles ID Volkswagen et bien
vous avez vos pédales avec un pose un
Play vous vous arrêtez quand vous
freinez vous mettez plein lorsque vous
roulez
[Musique]
et si vous voulez boire un petit coup
une canette ce que vous voulez mais
regardez vous prenez et vous pouvez
venir mettre vos petits gobelets et si
vous avez quand vous avez terminé que
vous soit tranquille vous prenez vous
refermez et autres qui est sympa c'est
que là vous avez la commande au niveau
des portes vous pouvez venir ouvrir et
fermer la porte arrière là c'est des
latérales coulissante pareil de l'autre
côté et là vous les fermez toutes vous
appuyez ça bien se fermer c'est pratique
c'est sympa voilà à côté du volant vous
avez ici un petit emplacement pour venir
mettre votre smartphone truc est très
très bien c'est que c'est un pas de
rechargement sans fil et si votre
smartphone ne surcharge pas sans fil et
bien vous avez deux prises usb-c et
c'est toutefois vous rechargez pas en
usb-c vous pouvez mettre un petit
adaptateur usb-c là j'ai perdu l'usba
mais également vers ce que vous voulez
donc ça c'est assez pratique juste
devant vous vous avez un tout petit
écran avec les informations essentielles
bon là il me dit que les portes sont
ouvertes ok c'est assez normal je vais
avoir la vitesse mon kilométrage mon
niveau de batterie mon autonomie je vois
exactement le pourcentage et après je
vois sur quel mode de conduite je suis
soit un mode démarré qui est assez
normal soit un mode B c'est mode brave
ça veut dire que lorsque je lève le pied
de l'accélérateur et bien ça va venir
freiner ça me permet d'avoir de la
récupération d'énergie et gagner un peu
en autonomie après j'ai mon neutre et
j'ai mon reculer ici directement au nous
avons un écran qui fait 10,15 pouces
alors moi je le trouve bien dans
l'ensemble parce que vous avez accès à
plein d'applications vous y retrouver
directement votre téléphone radio et
compagnie donc ça c'est un peu dans
l'idée de ce qu'on trouve sur un Android
vous voyez que vos applications bon ok
why not là sur le bouton centrale vous
allez arriver ici sur votre navigation
alors le côté navigation des fois je
trouve un peu moyen parce que on voit
pas réellement à quel moment il faut
sortir je trouve que c'est pas la
meilleure expérience que je vais pouvoir
retrouver ici après ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez quand
même Apple carplay et Android auto donc
si vous avez un smartphone que ce soit
un iPhone ou un Android et bien vous
pouvez venir le brancher ici profiterez
d'une expérience qui sera bien meilleure
voilà je trouve que des fois ça manque
un petit peu de repères on s'y retrouve
pas nécessairement ce qui est sûr si
vous voulez c'est que Volkswagen comme
tous les constructeurs un peu plus
classique ça sert de très belles
voitures mais pour l'expérience logiciel
ils prennent pas de risque là où est un
Tesla par exemple est très bon au niveau
du software mais ils seront un peu moins
bon au niveau du véhicule vous voyez il
faut vraiment savoir par quel bout il le
prenne je trouve que Volkswagen ici
prend pas trop de risques ils ont un
truc qui fonctionne c'est pas mal mais
quand on est dans un ID buzz qui a
véhicule hyper connecté avec des prises
USB tous les côtés des pleins de petits
détails on s'attendrait à ce que
l'expérience logiciel soit quand même
level up carrément plus haute en
proposant un truc génial une superbe
intégration avec des applications
dingues enfin bref une vraie révolution
au niveau du software chez Volkswagen et
ici c'est pas le cas on retrouve tout ce
qu'on attend mais pour autant on a pas
trop qu'on se dit ah c'est ouf c'est
génial c'est hyper fluide pareil là au
niveau des petits boutons c'est pas mal
c'est pratique mais il y a un truc qui
est pas extrêmement intuitif on sait pas
par quel boule prendre réellement donc
je trouve ça bien mais un peu tiède donc
je pense que le truc sur lequel il
faudrait Volkswagen eye c'est à vraiment
venir significativement travailler pour
améliorer l'expérience logicielle de
leur véhicule et notamment ici dans Lady
buzz ça serait vachement bien
voiture autonome est-ce que ça vous
parle c'est une voiture qui plus tard en
tout cas vous emmènera d'un point un
point B tout seul aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas par contre ça fait Volkswagen ici
ils ont mis plein de techno vous avez
notamment le travelassis 5 ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que lorsque vous êtes
sur autoroute au-delà de 110 km/h faut
pas rouler en dessous et bien votre
voiture elle va pouvoir changer de voix
toute seule vous mettez clignotante tac
elle va réguler sa vitesse dans le
trafic ça on le coller déjà dans plein
de marques mais ce que nous dit
Volkswagen c'est qui travaille
réellement pour aller sur la voiture
autonome on y est pas encore mais en
tout cas on a une bagnole ici qui est
bourrée de technologie et la volonté de
la marque c'est d'aller vraiment vers le
véhicule totalement autonome on y
arrivera plus tard et il y a notre truc
qui est assez marrant c'est le parc à 6
alors le parc assis c'est aussi très
très cool pourquoi parce qu'en fait
c'est votre voiture qui va venir se
garer toute seule alors ça c'est pareil
c'est les choses qu'on connaît déjà dans
différents véhicules vous appuyez sur le
bouton et elle se gare toute seule là il
y a un autre truc qui est assez sympa en
plus c'est qu'elle va venir mémoriser
les endroits où vous vous garez le plus
pour venir se garer de façon impeccable
6 millimétré donc la voiture autonome
même si c'est connecté c'est pas pour
tout de suite mais Volkswagen nous en
parle et si nous en parle c'est qu'il
sent que ça se rapproche il faut le
temps que le législateur avance
là-dessus mais quand ce sera prêt eux en
tout cas sont dans les starting blocks
et les enverront le bousin ça c'est
intéressant alors il y a un truc c'est
Lady Lighty light c'est quoi c'est une
bande de lumière que nous a mis
Volkswagen qui part d'ici au fond et qui
va jusqu'au bout de l'autre côté ça sert
à quoi là il dit light et bien ça sert à
vous avertir lorsque vous suivez le GPS
et qui va falloir tourner à droite et
ben vous allez avoir une bande de
lumière bleue qui part de là et qui va
jusque là-bas ok il faut tourner à
droite et pareil de l'autre côté ici il
y a une voiture qui se met à freiner
aussi fort devant vous ça va se mettre
en rouge donc l'idée c'est de vous
alerter alors je trouve ça marrant je
trouve ça assez pratique mais il y a un
truc lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
lumière globalement vous y voyez
vraiment pas grand chose la nuit on le
voit mais vous voyez qu'il faut tourner
à droite mais si par exemple vous avez
une ou deux trois sorties sur un
rond-point vous savez pas laquelle
prendre donc ça vient vraiment en
complément ici du GPS qui va venir vous
guider mais je trouve que ce truc est un
peu râler c'est que deux séries vous
n'avez pas de conduite à Théo et on
voudrait avoir une conduite à te haute
pour pour le coup vraiment voir où elle
est parce que là il dit Lite c'est bien
mais sans conduite à toi ça sert
réellement pas à grand chose donc c'est
bien c'est rigolo mais c'est assez
gadget alors la conduite tête haute va
arriver c'est une option qu'on va
pouvoir venir prendre ça j'ai déjà
essayé sur votre véhicule de Volkswagen
je crois sur Lady 4 et c'est vraiment un
truc que je viens recommander pour vous
aider à la conduite et des fois ça évite
de galérer de venir poser l'oeil
là-dessus qui est sur le côté ouais
c'est beaucoup plus sécurisant mais ça
c'est bien
[Musique]
que je trouve hyper marrant c'est que
pour voir qu'on est quasiment à 2 tonnes
4 on a 2 tonnes 4 c'est pas rien et bien
elle a de la puissance elle a de la
reprise sur l'électrique fatalement ça
part directement ça c'est super bien
alors il faut savoir que c'est une
propulsion ce qui nous permet d'avoir
effectivement cette rayon de braquage
mais voilà il faut pas craindre la
conduite en propulsion si vous êtes un
aventurier par exemple et que vous
voulez là où il y a de la neige
attention la propulsion il se peut que
vous restiez bloqué donc bon voilà ça
c'est des choses aussi à venir prendre
en compte lors du choix de votre
véhicule alors Volkswagen nous annonce
419 km d'autonomie et je vous cache pas
que je suis pas fait 419 km donc je
pourrai pas vous le dire le seul petit
point d'interrogation que je vais avoir
c'est sur la version cargo vous savez
c'est la version utilitaire est-ce que
on est vraiment à 419 si vous mettez une
charge qui est hyper lourde derrière
point d'interrogation je sais pas après
on a commencé quand même assez rapide de
5 à 80 %, vous le faites en une petite
demi-heure alors l'idée c'est pas de
descendre à 5% mais voyez vous maîtrisez
un petit 24 80 en permanence ça me
semble quand même vachement convenable
et c'est très très bien donc ça se
recharge vite ça plus bien c'est sympa
il y a encore des petites choses à venir
améliorer mais en termes de véhicules
électriques si vous voulez un peu le
côté van life ou même juste cargo pour
moi c'est un choix qui est très cool
voilà vous savez tout je vous ai tout
dit sur style Volkswagen alors c'est une
grande histoire on a commencé à les
courir en février on termine ici au mois
de novembre à Lisbonne alors on reste
Espagne Portugal c'est très cool la nuit
commence à tomber il va être l'heure
d'aller festoyer il y a des conseils il
y a plein de choses très cool ce
véhicule je l'aime bien je l'aime bien
parce qu'il est rasé parce qu'il est
intéressant parce qu'il est
technologique il sera pas peut-être pour
tout le monde on pense toujours quand on
veut un véhicule comme ça l'idée de la
liberté et si on part faire un grand
trip dans la montagne va-t-on pouvoir se
recharger comme on veut d'autant plus
avec les décalages de température ça
peut être un peu la limite mais pour
road trip sur des températures
maîtrisantes des endroits très sympa
c'est très cool vous savez il y a un
truc qui est marrant c'est que pendant
toute cette journée où on est venu
filmer ces deux jours on est venu filmer
et même avant on l'avait déjà vu au mois
de février quand on avait le véhicule
quand on se baladait les gens vous
arrêtent les gens vous interpellent ils
vous disent j'adore ce véhicule il y a
monsieur qui nous a dit moi j'avais
vendu les derniers combi avant il y a
très très longtemps quand c'était
fabriqué je crois au Brésil c'est ce
qu'il a dit quelqu'un d'autre arrivée
est en anglais qui nous a dit j'adore ce
véhicule je peux le regarder on a vu des
gens aussi qui venaient dukraine qui a
dit il est magnifique est-ce qu'on peut
prendre en photo donc on voit qu'il y a
un vrai au niveau du produit au niveau
de l'esthétique et une vraie attente au
niveau du Combi ça c'est juste génial il
est sympa c'est une version électrique
c'est une autre version nouvelle
aventure qui s'écrit ici par Volkswagen
avec de nouvelles technologies tout ça
super chouette alors vous dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez comment vous le
trouvez ça il dit boss est-ce que ça
pourrait vous botter est-ce que vous
verriez partir en long road trip avec
toutes les techno embarqués que vous
avez ici le mec j'en sais rien une
petite tente un petit feu de camp la
guitare on s'amuse voilà dites-moi ça
dans les commentaires nous on va
continuer de balade encore un peu
d'automobile beaucoup de technologie
bien évidemment parce que c'est le but
de la chaîne je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et moi je vais aller me
faire un coup de gratte autour d'un feu
de camp feu de bois voilà et ça c'est
chouette bisous ciao oh le vent de fou
[Musique]